hey youtubers Happy New Year awesome
news starting off 2017 right we just
found out that Miles Morales is probably
going to be in a new spider-man Sony
movie so I'm gonna explain what's going
on how that's connected to spider-man
homecoming and what the deal is there is
a new round of the spider-man giveaway
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video be sure to click that Bell to
enable alerts so you don't miss anything
so we got all this hype about Tom
Hollands version of Peter Parker coming
really soon this year like literally
coming this summer but now they're
ramping up for another spider-man movie
only the working title for this movie is
called cabin fever and they're casting a
young african-american / Porto Rican
teen from Brooklyn he's new to this
suburban school in feeling out of place
overwhelmed pressured with new
responsibilities and dealing with
puberty while trying to fit in he must
do his best to stay out of trouble along
the way in developing his identity he's
losing old friends but now making a new
one
Pete as in you know Peter Parker's what
they're implying so what they're
implying is is that they're casting
Miles Morales because that casting
description reads exactly like his
character part African American part
Puerto Rican understudy you know so to
speak to Peter Parker who takes him
under his wing if you don't know
anything about his origin story he was
this young kid in Brooklyn like the
description reads who's hanging out with
his uncle who just happens to be the
Prowler the character that Donald Glover
is playing in spider-man homecoming so
the Prowler had stolen a serum of
spider-man's blood that was developed at
Oscorp trying to engineer a new
spider-man
so Miles Morales visiting his uncle the
Prowler gets bitten by one of the
spiders in gains powers just like Peter
Parker had and thus begins the path to
him becoming ultimate spider-man but
it's kind of funny that his spider bite
is born out of something in a really
meta way that's happening in spider-man
homecoming with Donald Glover's
character but there been a couple
different versions of the character in
the animated series that we've seen so
far on the Disney cartoons this is not
that this is like full-blown Sony
animation movie so this is part of the
Marvel spider-man collaboration one of
the funny things about this is that you
know that donald glover is going to be
in spider-man home
coming as the Prowler well he actually
voiced the first version of Miles
Morales on ultimate spider-man so if you
haven't watched that before here's a
quick montage of the character on the
ultimate spider-man cartoon oh what's up
with me
nothing really just falling through a
wormhole between parallel worlds and
orders dot my archenemy the Goblin from
collecting the DNA of spider-man's from
alternate realities traffic jams
Broadway wanna tease you
cabbies and maybe I'm finally home sweet
home where I'm the one and only
spider-man
poor I'm totally wrong
easy pickings a small spider-man
did you call me small what happened to
you is it the supervillain diet cuz I
remember when you were big and scary and
stuff you want to see scary
beuker
[Music]
[Applause]
coming to my parlor said the Goblet to
the spider no I'll never make it in time
- huh
let me explain I am you from an
alternate universe and I know pretender
there's only one cool
yikes I'm an ultimate spider-man that
must be an ultimate Goblin
you're not me nothing so we can trail
could be made
oh I'll catch up to Goblin later now I
better get this world Spidey somewhere
safe you okay
Oh musta hit my head pretty hard because
you look like Peter Parker you're not my
secret identity oh of course you do
you're a Peter Parker too don't freak
out I'm you whoa whoa whoa I'm not you
you're dead which makes me dead
no way neither of us could be dead
that's impossible Peter Parker so you're
not dead
I'm not what now okay don't freak out
huh my name is Miles Morales and I'm
Spyder we're not ghosts right because if
I'm dead my mom and dad are gonna kill
me
you're spider-man but you're so young
what are you gonna do card me I'm 13
almost 14 in the lebanon's sorry just
didn't expect such a young spider-man
listen this is complicated and not gonna
make a lot of sense but I'm from a
parallel world makes total sense
so you chase the Goblin from your world
to this one and since he's goblin he's
probably after my DNA exactly
you're pretty good Spidey when you saw
me why did you think we were ghosts
you're not kidding
because this isn't a haha kind of topic
you really don't know what happened to
Peter Parker I mean you Peter Parker is
gone
yeah
no you don't understand I mean whoa yeah
each pair has had a little bit of juice
left enough to get all of you home
thank you for saving my world Thank You
spider-man for all you did for us for
making us believe for making us better
Spidey's
yeah what they said
who else would it be unless you know
some other superhero who spins webs and
sticks to walls and is late for a very
important date good
yeah that will not be my profile pic
Miles Morales here you know spider-man
and it's moments like this I wonder if
I'm really qualified to follow in Peter
Parker's footsteps or web steps are
watch that's the thing
hey personal space
I destroyed one spider-man already time
for another so greedy
think about the other supervillains that
want me dead I'm glad Peters no longer
around to see this
hello where'd you go mr. goblin why
can't all my battles end like this
nice just found my new profile pic Peter
Parker here your friendly neighborhood
amateur sleuth tracking Doc Ock and I
deduce he might have something to do
with that
Doc Ock with Baron Mordo Otto you have
the most bizarre friends from the dark
book of Asti
the passenger spell of our lives
thus far get baron morning
this guy's a wannabe dr. strange except
totally evil works for Hydra and isn't
even a doctor
let's see the Baron of anyway crazy town
you've been the silic spider you have no
idea what you've stumbled into is it a
rave oh and here I forgot my glow sticks
the siege perilous is normal party
accoutrement
the siege perilous a device that opens
portals to the other dimensions I'm
gonna guess this isn't good
he was pretty strong before he became
invincible the Goblin cannot be harmed
while holding it but the siege perilous
can be destroyed with an energy surge
then let me introduce it to my Iraq no
blacks no if we destroy it you'll be
trapped here lead on the way we did
before
time for a spider-man team-up files you
sacrificed everything well that is what
a spider-man does right hurry he could
have enough residual dimensional energy
for me to open a gateway and get him
back hold the cross world we knees of
one tomb
[Music]
mom I cannot bridge our world this is
but a window one that I cannot hold
where are you mom I'm sorry but someone
was in danger so it was your
responsibility to help I don't know how
yet but I'm gonna find a way back to you
I know you will
I love you miles
and it's all shiny and newly rebuilt
rebuild well odds are me of goblins kind
of captured everyone and zap them with a
mine ray and blew it up
wait what don't worry about it come on
I'll introduce you to the team no no go
back to the blue top part
meet the rest of the web warriors
iron spider agent fennel
and Scarlet Spider
another stray where'd you dig this one
yeah says the guy Spidey found in the
sewer I hate you look everyone I want
you to meet spider-man that spider-man
or actually both spider-man you can't
both be spider-man
okay let's be fair and square I'll be
spider-man
I called called it what are you 13
maybe what are you 150 look his name's
miles and he's the spider-man from
another dimension and he's kind of
trapped here temporarily well then
welcome to the team
spider-man wait what no I'm spider-man
I've been spider-man for like so for
those of you asking about him in the
live-action movies Kevin Feige said that
for the foreseeable future we're not
going to see him yet just you know
because when you consider his origin
story is picking up the mantle after
Peter Parker falls first you have to
introduce Peter Parker and they're just
doing that now he's a sophomore in high
school so they'll get to Miles Morales
eventually but it's going to take a
while to get there because Peters going
to be working his way through high
school in the spider-man homecoming
trilogy Harry Potter style like the way
those films followed those characters
through school
same thing with spider-man homecoming I
mean we don't know what the title of the
second and third movie is going to be
but they've already dated that second
spider-man movie for summer 2019 so what
it sounds like they're doing is is
they're just using the animated movies
to do all the stuff that they don't have
room for in the live-action films right
now like this big Marvel Sony spider-man
deal is huge it's going to take a while
to figure it all out but in addition to
all the live-action stuff there will be
a lot more marbled Sony collaboration in
that just taking the form of this big
animated feature and I know I just
played those clips of ultimate
spider-man on the TV show but it's not
going to be like that it's not going to
be like web warriors it'll be way
crazier Sony animation is kind of like
DreamWorks and DreamWorks Animation's
like a completely different studio so
let me know in the comments if they can
do almost anything they want in the
animated movies what else do you want to
see like they just teased spider-gwen
and Miles Morales in this issue here
they could do stuff like spider-gwen
they could do silk characters that the
live-action movies will probably have
eventually but I'm not expecting to see
spider-gwen in a costume or even silk
for that matter it's gonna take a while
to get there
so the animated movies just generally
don't have to adhere to a lot of the
same rules the live-action movies do
they can go there as fast as they want
but if there are any other Spiderman
bonus videos or Miles Morales videos
that you guys want me to do just let me
know in the comments I will say
congratulations to this week's Potter
Man giveaway winner kid Matsuda you win
a comiXology gift card it's busy like an
Amazon gift card so please private
message me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact details there
is a new round that started in this
video I'll just announce a winner the
next time I post a Marvel video while
you guys wait for that to post you can
click here for new spider-man homecoming
footage and you can click here to learn
all about Deadpool in the new Wolverine
movie thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight
you